madame azoulay
comment osez vous justifiez le concert
de black m à verdun black m
piliers d'un groupe aux textes
homophobes antisémite anti français
s'est il chante et peut-être sans doute
le talent n'excusent pas tout madame
azoulay
le gouvernement sait qu'il honorait la
mémoire l'histoire la nation
la réponse hélas et non et vous osez
madame azoulay dénoncer les républicains
qui s'ils condamnent ce concert qu'elle
inversion des valeurs
madame azoulay vous manquez de respect
vous manquer de respect à nos soldats
d'aujourd'hui vous manquer de respect
aux anciens combattants de toutes
générations
vous manquez de respect à ceux de verdun
à ceux de 14 18
vous manquez de respect madame azoulay à
mon grand père
shalom benkemoun croix de guerre
médaillé militaire tirailleurs algériens
qui n'aurait pas imaginé que vous
acceptiez qu'on le traite de
vous manquer de respect à la mémoire à
verdun qui a forgé l'unité de la france
cette unité que vous ne devez pas animé
par une telle provocation
cette unité que tous ici nous devons
être attentifs a démontré un manque de
respect mam le ministre aussi à l'état
quand françois hollande veut mobiliser
des moyens de l'argent pour financer ce
concert des moyens pour la sécurité
quand le gouvernement est incapable à
rennes et au delà d'assurer la sécurité
des français
alors madame le ministre pour l'unité
pour l'honneur de la france où il a eu
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
manuel valls
on écoute la réponse du premier mené ses
veaux plec ce le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
mariton vous adressiez il y un instant à
madame la ministre de la culture et au
fond votre question est une bonne
illustration de ce que je rappelais il y
a un instant la violence des mots le les
bleus verbe utilisé pour créer de la
tension dans le pays pour créer de la
tension dans le pays
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est candidat à
la primaire de la droite qu'on doit
s'autoriser ses mots ces mises en cause
ces accusations et monsieur le député
mariton vous aurez du mal à faire quoi
ici dans cet hémicycle que le premier
ministre de la france que la ministre de
la culture puisse un seul moment être
prise en défaut de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
d'où qu'il vienne d'où qu'ils viennent
je me le demande je me demande s'il ya
éventuellement un personnage qui ne
connaît pas notre pays et qui assiste
pour la première fois à ces questions au
gouvernement
l'image qu'il peut avoir de notre
démocratie du parlement et de
l'opposition
quand on entend une telle question avec
de telles mises en cause les décisions
ont été prises concernant cette
malheureuse affaire la sphère elle est
derrière nous mais monsieur mariton ça
ne vous autorise pas ici dans cet
hémicycle avec le poids de l'histoire
avec la présence des députés alsaciens
au premier rang avec ce que nous savons
tous de la france ça ne vous autorise
pas ces mises en cause et expliqué que
le président la république cole
gouvernement que la ministre de la
culture comme secrétaires d'état aux
anciens combattants ni l'histoire mais
tant qu ce que nous sommes au contraire
dans ces moments là vous devriez être
capable de faire preuve de bon sens et
de faire en sorte que chacun pour une
fois sera sans monsieur le député
mesdames et messieurs les députés
il y en a assez de cette violence
verbale que cette mise en cause et je
vous le dis clairement les yeux dans les
yeux
nous nous tiendrons êtes toujours vous
mesdames et messieurs une grande partie
en tout cas de la droite toujours avec
ce même discours qui consiste à mettre
en cause ça ne rentre pas légitime
l'action
nous sommes là pendant cinq ans jusqu'au
bout et nous irons projet contre projet
pour vous dire que nous n'acceptons pas
cette violence cette manière de se
comporter et de mettre en cause l'action
de l'état
mais